In this Cloud Minute, I want to show you
how to deploy Microsoft SQL Server on a Google Compute
Engine instance. In Google Cloud Developer Console
Go to Compute Engine and create an instance
Give it a name, select its zone
and then machine type
For boot disk, choose one of the SQL Server images provided
And hit create
Once the instance is ready
You can create a Windows user and password and remote desktop
into it like any other Windows instance
Once logged in
You can use SQL Server Management Studio
to connect and manage the SQL Server instance
You can check out the links in the description
of the video for more information
Thanks for watching!